Bitte gerne.
Schönen guten Tag. Mein Name ist Frau Schäker. Ich bin hier als Assistan-Assistent. Heute möchte ich mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegeschritt durchführen. Sind Sie einverstanden?
Ja.
Bevor wir anfangen, muss ich schnell ein paar Personie-Fragen stellen. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Michaela Stuckmann.
Könnten Sie Ihre Vor- und Nachname langsam bestabieren?
Ja, Michaela schreibt sich M-I-C-H-E-L-A. Michaela.
Und der Nachname Stuckmann schreibt sich S-T-U-C-K-M-A-N-N. Stuckmann.
Frau Stuckmann, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 56 Jahre alt.
Und wann gehen Sie jetzt?
Am 1. März 1968.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,69 m.
Und wie wiegeln Sie?
74 kg.
74 kg. Okay, gut. Was für Sie so uns Frau Stuckmann? Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ich habe ungefähr seit ca. 10 Stunden. Aber ich brauche Schmerzen auf der rechten Seite.
Und die sind in den letzten Stunden doch schlimmer geworden.
Und das macht mir Sorgen und deswegen bin ich heute zu Ihnen gekommen.
Okay, ich habe eine gute Entscheidung getroffen. Aber haben Sie Schmerzen plötzlich begonnen oder langsam?
Nein, langsam. Die haben langsam angefangen.
Könnten Sie diese Schmerzen genauer beschreiben?
Sie sind mehr dumpf.
Und teilweise auch so ein bisschen wellenförmig, aber nicht immer.
Aber hauptsächlich sind Sie dumpf.
Okay.
Strahlen Sie Schmerzen irgendwo auf?
Ich habe den Eindruck manchmal in die rechte Schulter.
Rechte Schulter, okay.
Sind Sie Schmerzen in oberen Bauch oder unteren Bauch?
Rechte Teil.
Ja, ich glaube eher so in der Mitte mittleren Bauch auf der rechten Seite, aber mittel und oben.
Der Mitte und ober.
Wie würden Sie die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskalaphone 1 bis 10 bewerten?
Wenn 1 leichte Schmerzen und sehr starkeste Schmerzen bedeutet?
6.
Okay.
Gibt es bestimmte Auslöser?
Haben Sie etwas bemeint?
Du zum Beispiel Essen.
Ich war am Tag vorher, war ich einem Jubiläum eines Kollegen, Arbeitskollegen.
Und da gab es schon viel zu essen und es hat so gut geschmeckt.
Aber ich habe es sonst vertragen.
Aber es kann sein, dass es mit dem Essen zu tun hat.
Ich weiß es nicht genau.
Okay, okay.
Aber meinen Sie gestern oder vorgestern?
Vorgestern.
Okay.
Gibt es etwas das Schmerzen verstarke oder lindert?
Zum Beispiel, bestimmt eine Medikamente?
Nein, ich möchte mich eigentlich nicht gerne bewegen.
Ich möchte lieber ruhig liegen, auf dem Rücken liegen.
Das tut mir ganz gut.
Aber mehr kann ich dazu nicht sagen.
Haben Sie dagegen eine Medikamente?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Froschtuckmann, kennen Sie diese Schmerzen?
Hatten Sie früher schon einmal?
Nein, solche Schmerzen habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Erst einmal, okay.
Ist Ihnen übel oder mussten Sie sich übergeben?
Ja, mir ist ziemlich übel und ich habe auch zweimal bisher erbrochen.
Wie sieht das Air Broken aus?
Na, ich würde sagen so gelblich schleinig.
Haben Sie Blut bemerkt?
Nein.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Leiden Sie unter Bedurchfall?
Stuhlgang ist bei mir immer regelmäßig.
Zuletzt war das vielleicht, der letzte Stuhlgang war kurz bevor die Schmerzen anfingen.
Also nichts Besonderes.
Und Wasserlassen habe ich keine Schmerzen.
Ich muss nachts ein bis zweimal auf Toilette.
Aber das hängt davon ab, wie viel ich abends trinke.
Wie viel Mineralwasser ich trinke oder wie viel Tee.
Ich möchte sicher sein, haben Sie diese Schmerzen seit 10 Stunden?
Ja, seit 10 Stunden.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Okay, haben Sie Brustschmerzen oder Engelgefühl oder Druckgefühl?
Nein, nein.
Haben Sie öfter Zutberänen oder Zauber aufstoßen?
Nein, da habe ich keine Beschwerden mit, keine Probleme.
Gut, haben Sie Fieber?
Ja, ich habe vor 2 Stunden Fieber gemessen, da hatte ich 38,3.
38,3, okay.
Wo haben Sie gemessen?
Im Mund.
Leiden Sie Katzschweiß oder schwitzen Sie so viel?
Nein, nein.
Leiden Sie unter Nachtschweiß generell?
Nein.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ab oder zugenommen?
Nein, ich habe mein Gewicht in den letzten 2 Jahren gehalten.
Gut, okay.
Ja, gut.
Froschtutman, möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen über Ihre Beschwerden?
Nein, nein.
Jetzt würde ich Sie nach Ihrer Vorgeschichte etwas fragen.
Leiden Sie an chronische Erkrankungen, wie z.B.
Bulletsuckerkrankheit oder Bulletshochterung?
Also ich habe Asthma seit der Kindheit.
Da bin ich auch getestet worden auf Hausstaub,
Hausstaub, Milbe und Pollen, besonders im Frühsommer.
Jetzt gerade um die Zeit rum, so von April ab bis Juli habe ich
auf Probleme und bin auch schon mal mit Spritzen behandelt worden,
aber das hat nicht so viel geholfen.
Ich muss regelmäßig Spreis nehmen.
Damit geht das ganz gut.
Was ist Spray?
Das Spray heißt Atmadesk.
Sie benutzen aber nur im Frühjahr.
Manchmal muss man das auch im Herbst und Winter nehmen,
weil es ist ja auch Hausstaub.
Ich bin ja auch Hausstaub empfindlich.
Im Frühjahr muss ich es besonders nehmen,
wenn dazu noch die Pollen kommen, die Pollenunverträglichkeit.
Also eigentlich nehme ich das Spray das ganze Jahr über.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Ich nehme es zweimal am Tag und wenn es mal stärker ist,
dann nehme ich auch noch Salbutamol Spray.
Das ist zweimal am Tag, morgens und abends?
Ja.
Haben Sie noch weitere Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich habe Probleme mit der Schildrüse.
Ich habe eine Schildrüsenunterfunktion seit meiner Fibertät.
Da muss ich anfangen, weil die Schildrüse auch vergrößert.
Aber seitdem ich Tabletten nehme, da ist die Schildrüse auch etwas kleiner geworden.
Die Schildrüsenwerte sind jetzt gut, aber ich muss die Tabletten immer weiter nehmen.
Okay, welche Tablette nehmen Sie ein?
Das Mittel heißt El Tyroxin.
Kennen Sie die Dosis?
Da steht hinter 75.
Dann nehme ich eine Tablette morgens.
Tabletten morgens, okay.
Dann habe ich auch noch eine, der Arzt sagt immer, ich habe eine eingeschränkte Nierenfunktion.
Weil ich hatte früher in der Kindheit häufig Handwegsinfekt und auch Nierenbeckenentzündungen.
Das muss regelmäßig alle sechs Monate, muss desernieren Wert kontrolliert werden.
Der ist immer etwas erhöht und ich gehe auch einmal im Jahr zum Neff-Volumen kontrolliert.
Aber im Augenblick ist das stabil, aber das muss immer kontrolliert werden.
Momentan, aber alles in Ordnung.
Okay, nehmen Sie noch weitere Medikamente ein?
Nein.
Frau Stuckmann, würden Sie schon einmal operieren?
Ja, als Kind, aber ich 12 Jahre alt, wollte ich an den Mandeln operieren.
Und dann hatte ich zweimal bei den Geburt, meiner Kinder waren Kaiserschnitte.
Und die Kinder sind jetzt 29 Jahre alt und 32 Jahre alt.
29 und 32.
Ja gut.
Frau Stuckmann, haben Sie allergene oder Unverträglichkeiten?
Unverträglichkeiten nicht, aber Allergien habe ich eben Hausstaub. Hausstaub und die Polym.
Ja, okay.
Sonst habe ich aber keine Allergien.
Okay, rauf uns die.
Nein, habe noch nie geraucht.
Gut, das riecht mich.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, aber nur selten. Also mal auf einer Feier oder bei Geburtstagen oder so, aber nicht regelmäßig.
Vielleicht einmal, zweimal im Monat vor, dass ich ein Glas Wein trinke.
Aber sonst trinke ich keinen Alkohol.
Mhm, gut.
Die nächste Frage ist eine Routine Frage. Bitte nehmen Sie nicht persönlich.
Aber nehmen Sie Drogen oder haben Sie Erfahrung?
Nein.
Mhm, gut.
Frau Stuckmann, jetzt würde ich Sie nach Ihrer Familie gesteht, was Fragen.
Leiden Ihre Eltern an chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, der Vater, der ist 82 Jahre alt.
Der hat hohen Blutdruck schon seit Jahren.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie lange.
Da muss er auch Medikamente nehmen, aber die kenne ich nicht.
Und er hatte vor 10 Jahren, hatte Atamkrebs.
Und da wurde er operiert und bekam auch danach noch Chemotherapie.
Aber es geht ihm jetzt ganz gut.
Er wurde immer kontrolliert, fünf Jahre lang.
Das fühlt sich ganz gut.
Sehr gut.
Und jeder Mutter?
Die Mutter, die ist auch 82 Jahre alt, die hat Alterszucker.
Und die hatte vor 20 Jahren eine Gallenoperation wegen Gallensteinen.
Okay, und haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, eine Schwester, die ist 58 Jahre alt, die hat auch Asthma.
So wie ich.
Asthma hat sie und vor einem Jahr wurde bei ihr auch die Gallengleise operiert.
Okay, okay.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich wohne mit meinem Mann zusammen.
Die Kinder wohnen aber inzwischen woanders in einer anderen Stadt.
Ja, sie sind momentan erwachsen, aber sind Sie gesund?
Ja.
Asthma, sind Sie in den Wechseljahren?
Ja, meine Periode ist nicht mehr regelmäßig, schon seit zwei, drei Jahren nicht mehr.
Aber ich gehe regelmäßig zur Gynäkologin, zur Vorsorgeuntersuchung.
Und das war sehr immer unauffällig.
Okay, und die letzte Frage.
Treiben Sie Sport?
Nein, habe ich früher gemacht, aber in den letzten Jahren nicht mehr.
Da bin ich etwas faul geworden.
Ich sollte vielleicht etwas mehr mich bewegen.
Ich gehe spazieren und bei etwas Fahrrad aber mehr nicht.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Wie bitte?
Ich bin Schneiderin.
Ich arbeite in einer Textilfirma.
Ich bin mit meinen Fragen fertig.
Frau Stüttmann, möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder etwas fragen?
Ja, was kann das sein?
Was kann ich haben?
Das macht mir Sorgen, weil ich so etwas noch nie gehabt habe.
Ja, ich verstehe Ihre Sorge.
Jetzt ist so früher eine Diagnose, so Schitellen,
aber wahrscheinlich haben Sie keine Blase in Sündung.
Ich erkläre Ihnen jetzt,
wie wir das machen.
Ich werde Sie körperlich untersuchen und etwas Blut abnehmen.
Danach machen wir manche Bildgebände untersuchen.
Zum Beispiel Bauchultraschern.
Danach werde ich mit meinem Oberratsschiff sprechen.
Von allen Ergebnissen vorlegen können wir eine richtige Diagnose stellen.
Okay, gut.
Danke schön.
Dann haben Sie jetzt etwas Zeit?
Ja, aber erst mal haben Kollegen und Kollegen noch eine Frage.
Einmal eine Frage.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft gegen Kinderkrankheit und Covid?
Ja, ich gebe meinen Impfpass immer bei der Hausärztin ab.
Alle zwei Jahre gibt es diese Check-Untersuchung.
Ich bin vollständig für Deutschland geimpft.
Covid, ja.
Ja, habe ich vier Impfungen.
Okay, danke.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Haben Sie Veränderungen im Stuhl bemerkt?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Und haben Sie wie viele Veränderungen bemerkt?
Urin.
Urin habe ich keine Veränderungen bemerkt.
Okay, danke schön.
Keine Kollegen haben keine Fragen.
Deswegen...
Wie ist jetzt noch etwas eingefallen?
Ich möchte ein paar Fragen stellen.
Ja.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass Ihre Haut oder Augen in letzter Zeit merklich geworden sind?
Nein.
Könnte es letzte Malzeit wegen Perdurben sein?
Das kann sein, aber ich habe jetzt keinen Durchfall oder so etwas.
Also, ich weiß es nicht. Es kann sein.
Ich weiß nicht, ob andere Menschen, die vielleicht Ähnliches gegessen haben,
oder das auch gegessen haben,
weiß ich nicht, dass sie Ähnliches oder solche Symptome haben.
Okay.
Ich bin nicht bekannt.
Und die Schmerzen, die Sie gerne ausbekommen?
Nein.
Ja, hat die Kollegin eben gefragt.
Ich habe gesagt, etwas in die rechte Schülter.
Wir haben Familienanalyse.
Deswegen lässt seit etwas Vorsorge, Untersuchungen haben Sie gemacht.
Zum Beispiel Ultraschall-Untersuchung.
Ultraschall-Untersuchungen macht der Nefrologer.
Einmal im Jahr macht der Ultraschall der Nieren.
Der untersuchte die Nieren mit Ultraschall.
Er hat vor, glaube ich, 2 Jahren, oder wo, hat er gesagt,
dass er an der Gallenblase 2 Steine sieht im Ultraschall.
Okay, danke schön.
Ich denke, alle Fragen gestellt.
Oberarzt, können wir als Erzitschsprach anfangen?
Habsar?
Ja.
Bitte schön, Herr Schnepper.
Okay.
Guten Tag, Herr Oberarzt.
Heute habe ich eine neue Patientin aufgenommen.
Darf ich vorstellen?
Ja.
Unsere Patientin heißt Michaela Stuckmann.
Frau Stuckmann ist 56 Jahre alt, 74 kg schwer, 1 m 69 gross.
Frau Stuckmann kam uns seit 10 Stunden bestehende, prokretierendere, rechte Abdominalschmerzen.
Die Schmerzen seien langsam aufgetreten und würden in rechte Schulter ausgestrahlen.
Die Patienten beschreibt die Schmerzen dumpf.
Die Patienten beschreibt die Schmerzen als dumpf.
Und wählen für mich.
Die Schmerzen sind stetlich auf einer Schmerzskala bei 6 vor 10.
Sie berichtete als Auslöser, dass sie vorgestern in einem Feier besucht.
Und dort habe sie viel gegessen.
Aber sie gab am früheren, sie gab am, dass sie früher ähnliche Beschwerden nicht gehabt.
Ja, nicht hatte.
Sie knackte über Auslöse, Nausea und Emesis. Sie musste 3-mal übergeben.
Ich habe eine Frage. Sie knackte über oder begleit Symptome.
Was haben, ich, was können wir nennen?
Sie können sagen als Begleit Symptome oder die Patientin klackte über.
Aber diese begleit Symptome, sie klackte über, die Symptome sind nicht ein Problem.
Aber sie klackte über, die Symptome sind Patelleprobleme.
Aber diese begleit Symptome, sie, sie, sie seien folgende Begleit Symptome aufgefallen.
Nausea, Emesis zum Beispiel.
Wo kann man das so sagen, ja? Durchaus.
Danke schön.
Okay, ich kann so sagen sagen, als Begleit Symptome klackte sie über, Nausea und Emesis.
Sie musste 3-mal übergeben. Er war geblich und schleimig. Aber sie habe keine Blut gemessen.
Also, indem sie haben, viel war seit 2 Stunden und 36,3 gemessen.
38,3.
Ach, sorry. 38,3 im Oral gemessen.
Ja, in Vegetarie von Amnese berichtet sie über Nectury.
Sie muss 2-mal in der Nacht auf die Toilette gehen, wenn sie am Abend so viel trinken.
Ja, mein Vorschlag, mein Vorschlag, sagen Sie, die Patientin berichtet über 1-2-malige Nectury je nach Trinkmenge.
Je nach Trinkmenge, dann ist das genug. Brauchen Sie gar nicht weiter noch sagen.
Also, Sie berichtet über 1-2-mal Nectury je nach Trinkmenge.
Okay.
Anfordererkrankungen sind allergische Asthma-bronchiale, Hypothriose und Glomelonephritis sind bekannt.
Pioronephritis. Pioronephritis.
Ja, Pioronephritis bekannt.
Ja, ich würde sagen, an chronischen oder an chronischen Erkrankungen besteht ein Asthma-bronchiale, eine kompensierte Hypothriose.
Jetzt kompensierte Hypothriose. Sie hat ja keinen mehr, sondern sie ist ja kompensiert.
Anamnestisch wohl eine kompensierte Niereninsuffizienz. Die Patientin hat besprochen, meine Nierenfunktion ist nicht ganz in Ordnung.
Bei anamnestisch-rezidivierenden Pioronephritiden in der Kindheit.
Ja, in der Kindheit waren diese Pioronephritiden später nicht mehr, aber da hat vielleicht die Nierenfunktion im Rahmen dieser Infekte einen Schaden bekommen.
Gut.
Sie nehmen L-Troxin 75 Mikrogramm, einmal morgen regelmäßig und Atma-Disk-Spray, 2 Mal pro Tag, nehmen Sie auch ein.
Anfroporationen sind Ton-Selectomy.
Sie nehmen noch einen Spray ein. Sie nehmen Atma-Disk ein und Salbutamol.
Salbutamol bei Bedarf, aber das würde ich zumindest erwähnen.
Gut.
Anfroporationen sind Ton-Selectomy mit 12 Lebensjahren und Sexiosaserie vor 29 Jahren und vor 37 Jahren begleitet.
Neuropfen, 32.
29 und 32 Jahre.
Ja, genau.
Sie haben Haustraub und Polenallergie, die sich mit Asthma-Bronchiale aussetzen.
Sie sind nicht Raucherin und trinken gelegentlich Alkohol, 1 oder 2 Gläswein pro Monat, Drogenkonstum für den Vernein.
Bei der Familie Annamnese ergab sich folgendes.
Ihr Vater ist, ihr Vater sei, seit 80 Jahren alt.
Er leidet an arteriellen Hypertonien und er liebt vor 10 Jahren Kolonkarsinum, aber er wurde operiert und er habe Chemotherapie bekommen damals
und momentan habe er kein Problem.
Okay, gut.
Und ihr Mutter sei 80 Jahre alt, sie leidet an Diabetes Militistopsiwal und sie wurde Colesistectomy operiert.
Ja, oder scholesistectomiert.
Ja, ja.
Und sie, unsere Patientin hat eine Schwester, sie sei 56 Jahre alt, sie leidet an Asthma und Militant.
Ja, die Schwester ist 58 Jahre, die Patientin ist 56.
Patientin 56 und die Schwester ist 58.
Sie wurde auch Colesistectomiert.
Okay.
Unsere Patientin sei verheiratet, habe zwei erwachsene Kinder und wohne mit ihrem Mann.
Sie sei Schneiderin von Beruf.
Sie, ja, und sie sei vollständig geilf, sie treibe nicht regelmäßig Sport
und sie habe seit zwei, drei Jahren unregelmäßige Periode, aber sie besuche ihren Arzt, Frauenarzt
und diese Arztbesuch sei unaufgängig.
Okay, was ist denn Ihre Verdachtdiagnose?
Meine Verdachtdiagnose lautet Colesistitis und dafür schifre hin obere Rechte ab dem Nährschmerz sind,
das ist eine Bewelle für mich aus Zutralen in der Rechte Schulter und Familiegeschichte.
Frauengeschlecht, vielleicht übergewit, aber nein, nicht übergewit.
Leicht febrile Temperaturen?
Ja, Temperaturen auch.
Was ist denn differentialdiagnostisch zu erwähnen?
Differentialdiagnostisch kommen akute Pankreatitis, akute Gastritis und vielleicht akute Pankreatitis im Betrat, aber nicht so stark.
So weiter Abklären würde ich so erst körperlich untersuchen und Blutabnehmen für Laborkontrolliere,
ich Blutbild, Entsündung, Parameter, WCRP, BCG, Leberwerte und Nierenwerte, Amylasellipase und Colestaswerte.
Ja, und ich werde auch EKG verschreiben und Abdomenärsoneografie ist auch sehr wichtig.
gegebenfalls würden wir MRCP-Pilane.
Okay, kann es auch eine Appendicitis sein?
Agentinein.
Warum?
Die Entsündung ist nicht im unteren Bereich und dieser Partien ausgestrahlen.
Im rechten Schulter ist typisch für Colestitis, nicht Appendicitis.
Ja, gut, ich habe ja nur gefragt. Kann es auch eine rechtsbasale Pneumonie sein?
Ja, genau. Aber ich habe nicht über Fustin oder Atemnotdyspne gefragt.
Aber ja, es könnte sein.
Das würde ich zumindest in die Differentialdiagnose manchmal in einer rechtsbasale Pneumonie sehr atypisch sein.
Also nicht klassisch mit Atemschmerz, mit Husten und Dispne oder Ausbruch.
Zumindest sollte man daran denken.
Aber ich finde die Herableitung ihrer Diagnose, warum, verdacht auf akute Colestitis, finde ich sehr treffend.
Die febrilen Temperaturen, die familiäre Vorgeschichte, der ausstrahlende Schmerz in die rechte Schulter, die Lokalisation.
Ich habe nur etwas gefragt, um sie etwas zu stressen, um sie etwas zu verwirren.
Ja, gut, ich finde, das haben Sie sehr gut gemacht, sehr systematisch und verständlich und haben sich nicht aus der Ruhe bringen lassen,
haben versucht, Ihr Schema durchzuziehen, bilden Sie ruhig einfache Sätze, denken Sie an die Nükturisagen Sie,
nur es besteht eine ein bis zweimalige Nükturie, obhängig von der Trinkmenge.
Dann brauchen Sie nicht umständlich einen Satz noch zu formulieren.
Das ist manchmal dann leichter.
Ja, aber ich glaube, wenn Sie jetzt noch weiter trainieren, dann ist die Prüfung für Sie kein Problem.
Danke.
Gut, dann würde ich sagen, wenn sonst keine Fragen mehr sind, sollten wir uns wieder nächste Woche Donnerstag verabreden.
Okay, können wir diese Schmerzen postprandial nennen oder nicht?
Ich habe das nicht verstanden.
Was können wir?
Können wir postprandial anfangen, Schmerzen nennen oder nicht?
Aber postprandial wäre ja etwas, so jetzt, ich esse jetzt eine Mahlzeit, jetzt, und ich habe vielleicht nach einer halben Stunde Schmerzen.
Okay.
Das wäre postprandial, nach der Mahlzeit, postprandial.
Wahrscheinlich so ein Zeitraum von bis zu zwei Stunden nach dem Essen würde ich sagen, kann man von postprandialen Schmerzen sprechen.
Wellenförmige Schmerzen, undulierende Schmerzen.
Man kann undulierende Schmerzen sagen, aber das Wort Wellenförmig ist, denke ich, auch im Fach medizinischen akzeptiert.
Okay. Und die Patientin hat gesagt, sechs eine Schmerzkala.
Können wir eine Reaktion zeigen, zum Beispiel, diese Schmerzen einbischen aushalten und so weiter, sagen oder nicht sagen?
Ja, man kann das anbieten, aber die Patientin hat bisher ja keine Schmerzmittel genommen.
Und man kann das jetzt ruhig sagen, können wir im Augenblick noch abwarten mit Schmerzmittelgabe und ja, das würde ich zumindest fragen, aber es ist jetzt nicht zwingend.
Wenn die Patientin sagt, ich habe schon vier Tabletten Paracetamol genommen und der Schmerz wird nicht besser, dann kann man natürlich eventuell anbieten.
Ich könnte Ihnen jetzt eine Infusion anhängen mit einem Schmerzmittel.
Dann kann man trotzdem erklären, ich würde aber lieber Sie gerne noch ohne weitere Schmerzmittel untersuchen.
Haben Sie so lange noch Zeit und Geduld?
Wenn Sie das anbieten, viele Patienten sagen, ja, das geht dann auch.
Vielen Dank.